eighteen years ago today Julie Chen
welcomed us into the Big Brother house
for the very first time now the reality
show is in its 20th season and Julie
joins me now hi Julie how are you hi
thank you - well how are you good did
you think that you would be hosting such
a great show for so long and still going
strong
never I did not think the show would go
past season one maybe even not even
complete season one you know there was
talk if her ratings didn't do well they
were gonna pull the plug and send
everyone home packing everyone gets
evicted on one night with no winner but
you know we always tell the houseguests
expect the unexpected
well we too have to expect the
unexpected I certainly didn't expect 20
seasons and to be going strong
it's the Julie Chen effect I love it now
the show does really well does have
these diehard fans that it kind of
really they really pick up on everything
that's happening on Big Brother how did
they help shape the show oh the fans you
know they get involved they don't just
sit there and watch and scream at the
television and we get them involved and
this season more than ever we have a new
thing where we're making a big brother
interactive this season because the
theme is technology and you simply go
online and you answer questions about
the houseguest and whoever is the
trending the most gets a power in the
game whoever's trending the least gets a
punishment at the house and it's been so
fun to watch you know our fans are so
loyal and we always get new fans and new
viewers who check it out every summer
which has helped us stay successful and
it's also helped with you know social
media and like viral moments you see
something on your phone and you've never
checked out the show and then you see a
viral moment you're like I need to check
that out and most people check it out
they stay yeah and the great thing about
Big Brother is not only did you get the
episodes but you get the 24/7 feed so
people are watching consistently do you
watch the 24/7 feet or just the episodes
I do and it doesn't matter if they're
doing dishes or brushing teeth or
cooking and it's you know in the middle
of the night they stay up late I it's
something I can't even explain there
doesn't even have to be drama and you
just feel like who are flying on the
wall and you feel like you're doing
something very naughty and and I'm just
I'm glued I lose sleep over the summer
because of it and you know this
component of Big Brother has been there
since 2000 we were the first show that
you could live stream because it was
strangers living in a house cut off from
the outside world live happening so you
know you could watch it on your computer
and now your phone I mean it's it's been
fascinating to watch and the fact that
you've been there since the beginning
and seeing them on 24/7 on a feed what
would your advice be for houseguests
that are being watched the whole time
never forget that nowadays what you say
and what you do lives forever
it cannot be erased and you will be
judged you know people are out there
watching every move you make viewers and
we live in a society where people like
to judge all right tonight's live
eviction has Sam and Steve on the blog
but Sam has a secret power
she seems unsure about using it how do
you see the eviction playing out tonight
well I always say expect the unexpected
we might not have an eviction tonight I
mean Sam and Steve are on the block the
rest of the houseguest doesn't know that
if they try to evict Sam she does have
this thing called a bonus life which
gives her a chance to stay in the game
she has to successfully complete a
challenge that I present to her on the
live show but if she pulls it off and
she's the one they try to vote out no
one's going home now they vote out Steve
that's a different story but right now
it is a house divided and it will be
down to a swing vote and it's anyone's
guess who the majority the house is
going to say they want to see gone and
this year what's so exciting about is
the whole technology aspect of it the
Chen BOTS will we learn more about that
you know the Chen bot came way before
the zingbot and let me just say that but
the Chen bot is much nicer because
zingbot has a personality as you know
Chen bot does not that's why the name
for me is Chen bot which makes me laugh
the first time I heard heard it like I
didn't really know what it meant but I
knew because of the name alone and then
someone sent me the link of me saying
throughout all the live shows but first
but first but first and it was that same
like dead look in the eyes the same
delivery different hairdo different
makeup different outfit and it's just
burst out laughing by myself in my
office like I am the gen bock so Ivan
Ivan braced my inner Chen bot
thank you so much Julie was great
talking to you today
Thank You Sangeeta have a great day bye